there is a place back
some say to survive it you need to be as
mad as a hatter
I am in such a weird process because I
mean I've never worked on some of it was
such pieces of a puzzle you know we use
so many different techniques that it
really didn't manifest itself shots
really didn't come in in full till the
very end so it was kind of guessing and
kind of thinking you have it straight in
your mind but you know it's a constantly
evolving thing so much of what you see
has been added afterwards we shot this
film basically in a big green room no
set very few props you just have to
imagine what's they have to work hard
and you've got to imagine with you know
just much more precision I find so I
kind of show it up I'm like alright
everything's green nothing's real and go
it is against my vows to harm any living
creature Crispin had yeah he had so many
more this yeah it is dope see some had
to walk upstairs do his stilts and then
have just one eye to swordfight on still
yeah it was kind of mad what he was
asked to do well we only did a little
bit of mocap we did pure animation
partial mocap and then live-action and
then some live action
but with partial you know I mean the
thing I wanted to do was not say okay
let's do motion capture because got
animal character got human characters so
we wanted the animals to be purely
animated but the human characters needed
to be like the Hatter or the Red Queen
or you know stained or the Tweedles
their lot they're humans but they needed
to kind of blend in with the Wonderland
world often you're doing a scene and
when you're actually doing a scene with
a person you're able to kind of bounce
off their energy and you understand the
tone and then when you're actually doing
a scene with the character that's not
there you don't know what they're gonna
be giving you know there's so much going
on in the film is so much complexity to
the image that if you were trying to do
something to you don't to be distracting
within the story this is the first time
a really gone digital we used we use the
dulcet for certain things we use the
Genesis for the other the dull so we use
before when we wanted to
really close and we needed to blow
things up I mean it was just a lot of
things because I wanted to use the real
people and not do mo capture where they
had sort of a veneer of animation over
them so it was like their eyes their
them but in this sort of slightly
mutated or redefined form rather be
large head to heaven very much like to
has it I used to have the white queen
her poor dear her head is so small tiny
it's a pimple of a head I had the huge
camera I didn't have to think about I
didn't ever think Oh big head acting
they just did they reminded me ever so
often that why I was much wider than I
thought you're not allowed really to put
your hand up to your face cuz your hands
gonna be in such a different proportion
to your head
it was weird working in 3d but then I
remembered that as a person I am in 3d
so it was okay do you know I mean I
thought oh yeah so I'm that I'm sure
I'll be okay so it was alright actually
we we filmed in 2d and then they made it
3d afterwards and now I'm actually not
joking
I had this big suit that from
head-to-toe pretty much that could track
my movements but my face was was visible
and it is actually my face that you see
on the two characters you can see things
that are shot well in 3d and shot crappy
in 3d and you see things that are shot
well with conversion and badly in
converted it just depends on what you're
doing I mean we did it this way is
because we had no real elements to deal
with and I also wanted to have control
over depth and wanted to have control
over how much we were doing it in terms
of you know depth perception and also
just wanted more control over the
elements that I that with the techniques
we were using people kind of go like oh
how can you do this or that it's like
you know what where did this world
become a place where there's one way to
do something you know I thought we were
all trying to open ourselves up
creatively use all sorts of techniques
and things and do all sorts of things
but it's like I don't know thank you I
try to focus on what ultimately trying
to achieve with the thing and use
whatever this technique that technique
whatever just because this is unique to
this film something's gonna be unique to
another film good
what did you do on this you were in a
booth weren't you I was just selling
food outside the studio at the camera I
desperately wanted to get on the squawk
amodal they wouldn't let me up
[Applause]